اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
بولندا
اسرائيل تتهم وايران بمهاجمه ناقله نفط
ببحر عمان والاسطول الامريكي الخامس يحذر
من تهديد طهران للمنطقه
مع دخول
الثالث النظام يواجه المحتجين بالاعدامات
والاعتقالات العشوائيه
تعود الى القمر برحله استكشاف لكن غير
ماهوله
ايه ده المشاهدين البدايه من تداعيات سقوط
صاروخان في بولندا فقط قال امين عام
قال ان لا دلائل تشير الى ان الهجوم في
بولندا كان متعمدا واكد ان التحليلات
الاوليه تشير الى ان الهجوم في بولندا تم
بصواريخ دفاعيه اوكرانيه
من اجراءاته الاحترازيه في الشرق بعد
الهجوم في بولندا واضاف بان حادثه بولندا
لم تكن تحدث لولا كثافه الصواريخ الروسيه
على اوكرانيا امين عام النيتو اكد ان
الحلف سيقيم الوضع في الجناح الشرقي
لتحديد الاجراءات المقبله كما تحدث عن
دفعهم المزيد من القوات البريه والبحريه
في الجناح الشرقي
الناس الجيش
المستمر ونحن بحاجه الى انتظار نتائج ليس
لدينا ما يشير الى ان هذا كان نتيجته هجوم
متعمد وليس لدينا ما يشير الى ان روسيا
تستعد لعمليات عسكريه هجوميه ضد الناتو
تحليلنا الاولي يشير الى ان الحادثه كان
على الارجح بسبب صاروخ دفاع جوي اوكراني
تم اطلاقه للدفاع عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه
ضد هجمات صواريخ كروز الروسيه لكن اسمحوا
لي ان اوضح هذا ليس خطا اوكرانيا روسيا
تتحمل المسؤوليه النهائيه لانها تواصل
حربها غير القانونيه ضد اوكرانيا
تدعم فكره نشر منظمات دفاع جوي على الحدود
البولنديه الاوكرانيه وعلى كل الحدود
الشرقيه لدول حلف الناتو ياتي ذلك بعد
سقوط كما ذكرنا اثر خاين على الاراضي
البولنديه نست
ريمنس اليوم
في المناقشات وسنتحدث عن نشر منظومات
الدفاع الجوي على الحدود البولنديه
الاوكرانيه وكل الجناح الشرقي للنيتو
اذكركم انه خلال قمه الناتو في مدريد قبل
بضعه اشهر توصلنا لاهميه نشر المنظومه في
الجناح الشرقيه للحلفه والحادث الذي
شاهدناه في بولندا يجعلنا نفكر في كيفيه
تنفيذ ذلك بسرعه البيانات لن تنفع التنفيذ
سيساعدنا على الدفاع عن انفسنا
المزيد معنا من بروكس المراس العربيه نور
الدين الفريدي اهلا بك نور الدين يبدو قال
لنا العنوان الرئيسي من قبل النيته هو
التهدئه وايضا من قبل الولايات المتحده
على راسه كيف يمكن ان يفسر هذه او تفسر
بالاحرى هذه اللغه
صباح اليوم عندما اشاد بلا صاله الرئيس
الدول الغربيه بشكل اساسي الناتو حلف شمال
الاطلسي عندما اكد بانه لا مؤشر على ان
روسيا تحذروا لي عمليات هجوميه عسكريه ضد
الحلف وبالتالي هناك تبادل لهذه الرسائل
همم التي تطمئن الجانبين اوروبا
عندما علمت صباح اليوم بانها ما حدث في
بولندا كان نتيجه صاروخ تابع لانظمه
الدفاع الجوي الاوكرانيه حتى وان كان بعد
التفاصيل لا تزال منقوصه وزيره الدفاع
البلجيكي كشفت عن بعض الشيء قالت ان
بقايا الصواريخ الروسيه وهي استخدمت لغه
الجمع وكذلك بقايا صاروخ من نظام للدفاع
همم الاوراني سقط في شرق اوكرانيا اهم كم
من صاروخ روسي سقط ام اما ان المواد كافه
هي تابعه انظمه الدفاع الاوكرانيه مما لا
شك فيها لتحقيقات لا تزالوا اجاني وبها
المزيد هناك ملاحظه غير مباشره لم تاتي
حقيقه في المؤتمر الصحفي وهي ان ربما بعض
الاطراف اذا اشتدت الحرب خاصه مع هذا
الشتاء البارد القادم وبعض الاطراف قد
تحاول توريد الدول المجاوره لاوكرانيا
لاوكرانيا وتوريد حلف شمال الاطلسي في هذه
الجبهه في هذه الحرب مع روسيا هذا ما حرص
عليه سواء كان الرئيس في في بالي والقمم
هناك
تفادي نريدين هذه قراءه المحللين من ناحيه
انه هناك من يريد لهذه المواجهه من هو
المستفيد من خلال هذه القراءات وبالمقابل
صحيح في تهدئه ولكن ايضا هناك حديث عن
تعزيز جبهه الشرقيه
لحلف الناتو كيف يمكن ان يفسر هذا ايضا
ميسون البارحه الرئيس هيلينسكي سارع لدعوه
حلف شمال الاطلسي بعقد اجتماعا على مستوى
القمه
ومسؤولون اوكرانيون طالبوا مره اخرى
بمنطقه الحظر الجوي التي يكتبونها من
الدول الغربيه وقالوا ان على الاتحاد
الاوروبي البارحه لم يحرجوا الناتو ولكم
قالوا على الاتحاد الاوروبي ان يفرض ذلك
ولكن الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يمتلكوا اي قدره
عسكريه على فرد هذه المنطقه الماليه كانت
رفضت ذلك اطلاقا وبالتالي مساله فرض حضره
منطقه الجوي في اوكرانيه من قبل حلف
الناتو هذه مساله مستبعده اطلاقا لان
الحلف لا يريد الدخول في مواجهه مباشره مع
روسي من ناحيه اخرى هناك تصريحات التي
صدرت المسؤولين في دول البلقان في عفوا في
دول البطيخ ميسون والتي تريد او تساند
فكره
مضادات جويه ومضادات للدفاع الجوي للحدود
الشرقيه بمعنى ان بامكانها اسقاط هذه
الصواريخ الروسيه داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
هذا ايضا ما لم
تفعله ولم تقوم به دول حلف شمال الاطلسي
والحلف ككل والولايات المتحده ايضا
الصواريخ الموجوده والدرع الصاروخيه
الموجوده في بولندا في بولي البطيخ في دول
في رومانيا بعيده جدا عن منطقه المواجهه
بين اوكرانيا وروسيا وهذا ما ربما ما يجعل
البعض في دول البطيخ يدفعوا ولكن عموما
دون البطيخ ثلاثه متحمسه جدا جدا للمواجهه
مباشره مع روسيا ولكن الرئيس كان حريص جدا
على هذا المراسل العربيه نور الدين شكرا
جزيلا لك
ومنها كيف قال مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
ميخايللو بودل ياك ان روسيا هي المسؤوله
عن اي حوادث بالصواريخ بعد شن الحرب على
بلاده واضاف في بيان المكتوب انه من
الضروري التمسك بمنطق واحد فقط وهو ان
روسيا هي التي بدات الحرب وتواصلها
بالمقابل طبعا روسيا النفط مجددا اي على
علاقه لها بالصاروخ الذي سقط في بولندا
لكريم من جانبه رحب بما اعتبره ضبطا للنفس
من جانب الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في رد
الفعل على سقوط الصاروخين في بولندا مشيدا
في الوقت ذاته بموقف بيضا ونيته الذي
اعتبره رصينا بشان حادثه بولندا لكريم
ايضا انتقد ما وصفه بالتسرع من بعض الدول
في مواقفها بخصوص سقوط الصاروخين في
بولندا مؤكدا ان روسيا تستهدف كل ما له
علاقه بالبنا التحتيه العسكريه الاوكرانيه
ايضا المتحدث باسمي وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ايجور كونا شينكوف قال ان الصور التي نشرت
من موقع انفجار في بولندا اظهرت شظايا
صاروخ اوكراني وانا اقرب ضربه لموسكو
لاوكرانيا كانت على بعد 35 كلم من الحدود
البولنديه
وعلى مسافه لا تزيد عن 35 كلم من الحدود
الاوكرانيه البولنديه
قال الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون ان
مجموعه العشرين بعثت رساله واضحه برفض
الحرب والتصعيد في اوكرانيا مضيفا ان
مجموعه العشرين تنسق مع بولندا لتحديد
ملابسات سقوط الصاروخين ودفع روسيا نحو
خفض التصايد
من جانبه قال المستشار الالماني قال ان
تداعيات الحرب في اوكرانيا تستمر اثناء
قيام قاد الدول العشرين بهذه الجوله مشددا
على ضروره انهاء الحرب والسحب القوات
الروسيه
تستمر وحرب روسيا ضد اوكرانيا بلا توقف
الهجمات الصاروخيه على اوكرانيا في كل
مكان محطه الكهرباء
الروسيه على اوكرانيا اثرت سلبا على
الاقتصاد والامن العالميين وسيدوم تاثير
ذلك حتى سنوات
اسمعوني جدا
تسرعت الولايات المتحده فقط
من قبل الولايات المتحده
ليس فقط عدم وجود رغبه لدى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لتوجيه توجه نحو
التصعيد يعني تصوره لو اتضحت بانه او لو
قالت رسميا 100% كل من امريكا وكل اعداء
لحلف انها تتدانا تلك الصواريخ التي سقطت
على الاراضي البولنديه كانت
الاوكرانيه السؤال يطرح نفسه
مع هذه الصاروخان يعني واضح تمام اوكرانيا
اطلقت
صواريخ هو يجب ان يكون هناك علامات
حول هذه الموضوع نعم نحن
بعض
منورات السياسيه من قبل المانيا التي قالت
لنا كانت الصواريخ بكره هنيه ولكن كل
مسؤوليه طاقه على روسيا بس سياسيه
فقط المانيا هي تصريحات خرجت من الناتو
بصوره عامه عندما قالوا انه لولا تلك
الصواريخ المكثفه الروسيه لما حدث هذا
الحادث وبالمقابل الان من العواجل
الخارجيه البريطانيه ايضا تتحدث عن هذه
المسؤوليه التي تقع على عاتق موسكو
لا يريد
من قبل كل شيء الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
همم
شمال الاطلسي لتوجه نحو مزيد من التصعيد
وفي نفس الوقت لا يريد
كل المسؤوليه على الطرف الاوكراني فلذلك
هناك هذه الكلمات
همم
يمكن ان نقول بنفس الطريقه لو يقترب من
الحدود الروسيه الى ما كان هناك الاعمال
العسكريه
ليس اكثر
انه رد الفعل هذا يعطي تطمينات لروسيا
بانهته لازال حتى هذه اللحظه على موقفه
بعد عدم المواجهه همم مع روسيا
انا اعتقد ان كل من روسي وحلف الناتو
يدركان تماما تضعيات من المواجهه المباشره
ما بينكم فلذلك
بوضع تمام
تجاه روسيا ولكن هذه
تتجنب الولايات المتحده
ليس فقط بسبب عدم وجود رغبه لدى الولايات
المتحده
نحو تصعيد انا اعتقد ان هناك ايضا سبب
الثاني وهو ان يوجد هناك تواصل المباشر ما
بين روسيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
الاونه الاخيره حول الازمه الاوكرانيه
مزيد من التواصل المزيد من المشاورات
بعض سيد انطري انه بالفعل ربما يكون هذا
الموقف هو غطاء لما يحدث تحت الطاوله ولكن
همم اوكرانيا يبدو انها غير راضيه القرار
بيد من برايك بالنهايه
القرار صاحب القرار نقول ذلك صاحب القرار
هي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه طبعا
اوكرانيا قد حاولت ان تستفيد من ما حدث في
بولندا ولكنها فشلت امريكا
ستكون هناك مشاورات ستستمر المشاورات
الضنيه بين روسيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بدون مشاركه اوكرانيا في نهايه
المطاف واشنط تبلغ عن نتائج تلك المشاورات
همم
ماسك المحل السياسي اندريه انديكوف شكرا
جزيلا لك
وفي اخبار قمه العشرين هن او ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان الرئيس
الاندونيسي جوكو ويدودو بنجاح اندونيسيا
في استضافه القمه وكذلك بالنتائج
الايجابيه التي توصل اليها القاده في
القمه مؤكدا على اهميه ما صدر عنها من
قرارات املا ان تسهم وبشكل كبير في دعم
التعاون بين دول المجموعه وتعزيز معدلات
النمو الاقتصاد العالمي
وعلى هامش قيمه العشرين المنعقده في بال
الاندونيسيه جرى توقيع مذكره تفاهم بين
السعوديه واندونيسيا للتعاون في مختلف
مجالات الطاقه تستهدف المذكره تعزيز
التعاون في مجالات البترول والغاز
الكهرباء وايضا الطاقه المتجدده اضافه الى
تعاون الرياض وجكرتا في مجالات الهيدروجين
النظيف والتحول الرقمي في الطاقه
على كل المزيد معنا من جزيره بال
الاندونيسيه مو فده العربيه ناديه
البلبيسي اهلا بك ناديه لا يمكن لنا الا
ان نتحدث عن
التوافقات والاختلافات في هذه القمه خاصه
في ظل البيان همم لنركز على ما يقال بانه
النقطه الرئيسيه التي اختلف عليها القاده
وهي ما يحدث في اوكرانيا او الملف
الاوكراني لن اقول للحرب عشان هي المشكله
الرئيسيه في نص هذا البيان بين روسيا
والدول الاخرى هل لنا رصد من يتفق ومن
يختلف مع هذا البيان من الدول ومن هو على
الحياد ايضا اكيد
ميسون الصوره واضحه تماما يعني الولايات
المتحده التي تقود هذا التحالف وهو تحالف
اوروبي بالدرجه الاولى مع الدول التي تؤيد
الولايات المتحده مثل اليابان وكان دواء
استراليا منذ اليوم الاول منذ الغزو
الروسي الى اوكرانيا كانت تقدم دعم عسكري
ودعم اقتصادي ودعم مالي تعت بان ما قامت
في روسيا وانتهاك سارق للقوانين الدوليه
لذا هذه الدول التي خرجت بهذه الصياغه
القويه جدا والتي قالت فيها بانها تدين
الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا لكن الدول الاخرى
طبعا هي ضمن مجموعه ال 20 بعضها مثل الصين
لن تقوم بادانه روسيا روسيا لن تقوم
بادانه نفسها وتركيا ربما تبقي على مسافه
من الحياد حتى تقوم بالتفاوض لدرجه طبعا
لانه تم تثمين موقف الرئيس اردوغان لانه
يساعد في طبعا تمديد هذه الاتفاقيه ل همم
لاصدار يعني السماح للحبوب بالمرور عبر
البحر الاسود وبالتالي لا لا نريد ان نقول
بان هناك انقسام بانه حتى دول مجموعه ال
20 ميسون كما تعرفين صوتت لاذنه روسيا في
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده لكن هي
الصيغه التي تختلف اليوم بالتحديد وهو
نهايه هذه القمه كان من المفروض ان يكون
يوم مساء سهلا يعني بدايته كان على
التركيز على المسوده وايضا على زراعه بعض
شجيرات المانجوغراف حتى يظهر الرؤساء
بانهم اصدقاء للبيئه لكن اضطر رئيس العقد
اجتماع طارق بسبب هذه الصواريخ التي اطلقت
على اوكرانيا روسيا لم تعفى من المسؤوليه
لانها بالفعل اعتبرها البيت الابيض هو
خطوه تصعيديه باطلاق كل هذه الصواريخ على
الاردن الاوكرانيه حتى لو تريهت الرئيس
وقال كما ذكرت قبل قليل مع ضيوفك بان
روسيا لم تطلق هذه اللغه
ايضا من قبل موسكو ناديه طبعا كان في
لقاءات ثنائيه لقاء الرئيس الامريكي ايضا
الصيني من همم لقاءات الرئيسيه المهمه
خاصه انها همم الاولى رغم لقاءات السابقه
همم
بسرعه لو استطعت ايجاز هذا اللقاء اضافه
طبعا على المستوى العربي همم لقاءات ولي
العهد السعودي
قال لي خالد الجماعه مهم جدا لانه كان
هناك نقاط اتفاق مبدئيه على عدم استخدام
الاسلحه النوويه وهنا اشاره الى كوريا
الشماليه
وطبعا روسيا هناك اتفاق على موضوع التغيير
المناخي هناك اتفاق حتى في الملف الايراني
وهناك اتفاق على فتحه هذه القنوات حتى لو
كان هناك تنافس تجاري بين الدولتين الا ان
بيض انقلب انه لا يسعى الى الصدام لكن اهم
نقطه هو التركيز على تايوان وتطوينات
امريكيه اذا اردت بان سياسه همم سياسه
الاداره لم تتغير الصين واحده ليش لا يجب
ان يضم اي طرف بالنسبه لولي العهد طبعا
يتوجه الى كوريا الجنوبيه اليوم بعد نهايه
هذه القمه كانت اللي هو العديد من
اللقاءات مع الرئيس التركي همم ومع رئيس
دوله الامارات مع رئيس الصيني مع رئيس
الاندونيسي كما تعرفين السعوديه لديها
ثقلها
ان تتوقع
قبل قليل الاند
مفاده العربيه ناديه البلبيسي شكرا جزيلا
لك على هذه المعلومات
وحول هذا اللقاء ما بين الرئيس الامريكي
والصيني طبعا اشار الى تحول في العلاقات
بين واشنطن وبيكين نحو اداره ما يوصف
بالمنافسه الشرسه بين البلدين بحسب ما
نقلت صحيفه ولستريد جورنال قالت الصحيفه
ان اللقاء بين الرئيسين على هامشي قمه
مجموعه العشرين في بال امتد لاكثر من
ثلاثه ساعات غطى القضايا الشائكه كخلافات
البلدين حول تايوان كما ذكرت ناديه وايضا
الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى
سبل ضمان عدم اندلاع التنافس بين الولايات
المتحده والصين في صراع المفتوح الرئيس
الصيني شدد خلال اللقاء على اعتبار بلاده
لجزيره تايون بانها جزء من الاراضي
الصينيه وفقا لما نقلت الصحيفه عن
مسؤولينا الصينيين
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
ينجح الرئيس الامريكي السابق بالعوده الى
البيت الابيض
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه نقلت صحيفتها
ارتس عن مسؤولين امنيين اسرائيليين
تاكيدهم ان ايران هي المسؤوله عن الهجوم
مسيره على ناقله نفط قبالته ساحل عمان
مسؤول اسرائيلي اضاف ان المسير المستخدمه
في الهجوم على الناقله هي نفسها التي يتم
توريدها لروسيا ويتم استخدامها في
اوكرانيا اضاف المسؤول الاسرائيلي ان
الهجوم يشكل استفزازا ايرانيا وخطا
استراتيجيا خطا استراتيجيا ارتكبه النظام
الايراني
مشاهدينا طبعا نتابع هذه العواجل رويترز
نقلا عنها تقول قوى الحريه والتغيير تعلن
التوصل الى اطار اتفاق مع الجيش السوداني
اذا تحولات في السودان نتابعها طبعا في
سياق نشرتنا اللاحقه على كل نعود الى
استهداف سفينه او ناقله النفط الاسرائيليه
اكد قائد الاسطول الخامس بالبحريه
الامريكيه الادميرال براد كوبر في تصريحات
خاصه ان اكبر تهديد لامن المنطقه
والاستقرار هياتي من ايران بشكل واضح
وموثق على حد تعبيره
ديسباسيتو
القرصنه تجاره البشر الهجمات على السفن
التجاريه والتهريب اكان تهريب سلاح او
مخدرات واكثر تهديد على المنطقه هي بشكل
واضح وموفق ايران عبر مشروعيها الصاروخي
من قبل وكلاء اضافه طبعا لمشروعها النووي
بازيد معنى من القاهره الدكتور محمد مجاهد
الزيات مستشار المركز المصري للفكر
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا بك دكتور
محمد اسمحلي انا ابدا بقراءه للمشهد الان
وهذا الاستهداف اذا كان فعلا ايرانيا همم
لماذا الان في هذا التوقيت وهل عدنا مجددا
الى حرب البحار ما بين اسرائيل وايران
يشير الى ما تم العام الماضي في استهداف
ناقله بترول ايضا اسرائيليه وهمم ادت الى
مقتل اثنين من العاملين على الناقله همم
هذا التوقيت بالذات يرتبط بعدد من العوامل
اهمها انه تصعد التوتر وال- هجمات او ال-
ال- الاعلاميه المتبادله بين الطرفين
واخرها تصريح وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي بانه
يستطيع ضرب جميع المنشات انا وائل ايرانيه
النقطه الثانيه انه هناك لقاء ما بين قائد
القائد المركزيه الامريكيه وفي زياره الى
تل ابيب واجتماعي مع القاده العسكريين
هناك ضمن دوله للقاء ما عدد من قاده
الجيوش في المنطقه والحديث على ان الهدف
الاساسي هو همم ايران بالتحديد وقدراتها
العسكريه النقطه الاخرى الاضافيه ان هناك
نوع من استعراض القوه يتم في بحر العرب
منذ عده شهور اداره حامله الطائرات وسط
نوويه امريكيه هناك وكشف عن الزياره من
زياره قائد الاسطول الخامس وقائد المنطقه
القياده المركزيه الى هناك فبالتالي ايران
تريد ان توجه رساله انها موجوده بالاضافه
الى ان ايران تريد ان توجه الانظار بعيدا
عن ما يجري في الداخل لان الازمه الداخليه
مستحكمه وتصاعد وسنغطيها ولكن دعني ان
اتحدث عن هذا
او هذه الرساله الايرانيه مقابل لها طبيعه
الرسائل التي يمكن ان تصل لايران ان كان
من الاجتماع في تل ابيب كما ذكرت او حتى
تصريحات التي عرضناها على العربيه والخاصه
بالعربيه من قبل الاسطول الخامس وقائده
والذي قال فيه انه ايران هي تهديد الاساسي
هل نتوقع تغير في التعاطي مع ايران
وتهديداتها
لا اعتقد ان الامور ستتوتر حتى الرساله
الايرانيه كانت رساله شكليه يعني لم
تستهدف الناقله بصوره كبيره واحداث اضرار
جسيمه هي كانت تريد بس ان تسجل موقف انها
تستطيع ان تهدد المصالح الاسرائيليه هنا
كنوع من الرد تستطيع ان تزيد به داخليا في
مواجهه الضربات المتصاعده او المتزايده
لاسرائيل خلال الشهور الثلاثه الاخيره
داخل سوريا هناك همم 20 اعتداء تمت ضربت
اسرائيليه هناك
مستشار المركز المصري للفكر والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه شكرا جزيلا لك
ده كان العوازل من السودان ننتقل الى
المؤتمر الصحفي لنتعرف على المزيد
بالتفصيل
واستكماله لكن هنالك تعديلات لابد الناس
والمكونات
الاخرى من العمليه السياسيه كذلك
مما فيها اللجان الحصانات كل المسائل اللي
موجوده عدم الافراد من العقاب لكن كل هذه
بتحتاج لمناقشه عام في مشاركه لكل اسر
الضحك
فوق الحريه
السودانيين ككل وكذلك وسير الاتحاد
فبالتالي لتفصيل حوله قضيه العداله
الانتقاليه ايضا قضيه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري في كلام كثير انه يتكلم عن انه
الحريه التغيير وضع في الوثيقه السوريه
وفي المناقشات استقلاليه اللي هو ديت قوات
الدعم السريع وعدم الكلام ده غير صحيح
الوصفه السوريه تكلم عن انه لابد من جيش
واحد لكن الجيش الواحد بتجيء في اطار
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري وفي خطوات كثيره
من ضمن ترتيب التنفيزات الامنيه ومن ثم
الاتفاق بين القوات ده حول جداول زمنيه
للوصول لجيش مهني واحد ونص على هذا الامر
في الوثيقه السوريه بشكل واضح لكن القصد
من هذه الخطاب هي وهو محاوله الصدام او جر
البلد للمعاركه بشكل الموجود ان احنا كلنا
بنومين بانه لا يمكن ان نمشي في اي بلد
بيتعدل الجيوش بجيش واحد ولكن هنالك حقيقه
لا يمكن ان نقص او نقص حوله كل هذه
اصلاح امني بشكل [__] واصوله للجيش واحد
بتطلب النقاش واضح وصريح بين جميع الاطراف
بما فيه قاده هذه القوات والمؤسسات لوجود
حول الجيش واحد وصول للترتيبات الامنيه
كذلك من المسائل اللي تم وكانت بالنسبه
لناديه مهمه جديده اطراف العمليه السياسيه
ودي طبعا برده واحد من العيش فيها اللي
كان رفضنا اهو انا لانه بدي اقراء للعمليه
السياسيه وبالتالي مثلا الاطراف السياسيه
بالنسبه لنهايه اطراف اللي شاركت في وثيقه
السوريه للمحاميين اضافه لكل قوى الثوره
اللي بنؤمنوا منهم فيما فيهم اطراف
العمليه السياسيه السلميه اللي كان وقع
حركات مسلحه ماجيزو موجودين في
الوسخه الدستوريه للمحامين اا حركات
المواقع الاتفاق جوبا الحزب الشيعي همم
الرفاق الاخرى في تجمع المحانيد في كل
اللجان المقاومه دي كل بالنسبه لنا يجزوا
من اطراف العمليه السياسيه لكن القوه
الاخرى او القوه الشارقه كانت مع انظمه
السابق هي مكسوره القوه اللي شاركت في
وصيغه المحامين وما مفتوحه لكل عشان برده
انه عمليه سياسيه في النهايه تكون مصداقيه
وليس عمليه سياسيه بالصوره اللي بتكون فوق
اخراج ومسيطر حوله كذلك من ضمن القضايا
اللي الناس تحدثت حوله محاما القوات
المسلحه وهي دي طبعا بيرضوا من المحامي
اللي وارد في الوثيقه السوريه برده عمران
على هذه المحامي انه دي مهام بصوره واضحه
وجيليه وموجوده في الوصيه ضد سوريا
لروعه اللي همم تم اقرار بواسطه المحامين
ان ده كمحام للقوات المسلحه خلال الفتره
الانتقاليه ايضا من المسائل اللي
ايضا
في السودان الحريه والتغيير تتحدث عن
التوصل الى اطار اتفاق مع الجيش السوداني
طبعا قالت ان هناك مرحله اخرى تتعلق
باعدال الانتقاليه وانه لن يكون هناك
توقيع على اتفاق نهائي دون كافه الاطراف
الثوريه طبعا هو فيكم بالمزيد حاله ورودها
وننتقل الان همم الى ملف الخامسه نقلت
صحيفه تلغراف عن المدير العام للمخابرات
البريطانيه الداخليه لكن
قول له ان ايران خططت لخطف واختيار 10
مقيمين في بلاده تاهمهم بانهم اعداء
للنظام كما اشار الى اتجاه ايران لتنفيذ
هجمات ارهابيه على الاراضي البريطانيه قال
ان موجه الاحتجاجات الحاليه دفعت النظام
الايراني لللجوء الى العنف لاسكات
المنتقدين اضافه ان ايران نقلت التهديد
الى بريطانيا مباشره من خلال اجهزه
المخابرات التابعه لها قال راينا 10
تهديدات محتمله على الاقل خلال شهر واحد
ومع دخول الاحتجاجات ايران شهرها الثالث
افادت وكاله مهر الايرانيه بان القضاء
اصدر حكما بالاعدام على ثلاثه من المحتجين
المناهضين للنظام من جانبها افادت مصادر
اعلاميه ناطقه بالفارسيه بان سلطات
تواصلوا اعتقال الصحفيين في اطار حملتها
لقمع الاحتجاجات مشيره الى انها وثقت
اعتقال او تهديد اكثر من 100 وعشره كتاب
وصفيين مؤخرا كما تحدثت المصادر عن اعتقال
لاعب كره قدم وايضا عن اعتقال حارس
المنتخب الايراني السابق برويز بروماند
بسبب مشاركته بالاحتجاجات
عبد الجليل
يا حبيبي
ما ذكرناه فيما يتعلق بالمعلومات
الاستخباراتيه البريطانيه عن تحرك ايراني
في الداخل البريطاني وتهديدات قبل قليل
ضيفنا كان يتحدث عن ايضا انه استهداف
ناقله النفط الاسرائيليه هي محاوله من
ايران لابعاد الانبار عما يحدث في الداخل
هل تؤيد بالفعل هذه النظريه هل ايران بدات
الان بتحريك اذرعها واين سيتركز ذلك
طبعا لم تبدا الان ايران بدات منذ بدايه
الاحتجاجات التي اندلعت قبل تقريبا شهرين
بدات بضرب وقصف مواقع الاحزاب الكرديه على
الاراضي العراقيه في كردستان في اقليم
كردستان العراق
وكانت هذه هي محاوله في واقع الامر
ايرانيه
لتوحي بان ما يتم همم في داخل ايران من
احتجاج هو مرتبط بوراء الحدود وكان الشعب
عايش في جنه وليست لديه اي مشاكل وهذه
الدول والاعداء دائما الاعداء هم الذين
يريدون تحريك الشارع والا ايران لا توجد
فيها شيء بريطانيا
على الاقل لماذا بريطانيا الان
بريطانيا
على على ايران همم كما همم فرض الاتحاد
الاوروبي وبالتزامن بريطانيا ايضا فرضت
عقوبات على ايران علاقات ايران مع الدول
التي كانت
تتفاوض معها حول النووي هذه العلاقات ليست
كما كانت قبل الاحتجاجات بدات هذه
العلاقات تتصدع لذا وارد بانه ايران ايضا
تحاول خلق حاله من الله امن في بعض الدول
حتى تضغط عليها السياسيا قد تغير مواقفها
تجاه ايران ولكن لا اعتقد هذا التصرف سوف
يؤدي الى نتائج سياسيه تبحث عنها ايران
همم هندخل الشهر الثالث وبالتالي كيف
تغيرت هذه الاحتجاجات ورقتها حتى اين
تتركز وكيف توسعت او تقلصت الاحتجاجات لم
تبقى محشوره في رقعه جغرافيه دون اخرى
تبدا من الشمال الغربي الى الشمال الشرقي
الى الجنوب الغربي والى الجنوب الشرقي لا
توجد مدينه لم تشهد احتجاجات خلال هذه
الفتره الاحتجاجات عمه كل المناطق
الاشعارات واحده لانه هناك الان بدانا
نستمع الى بعض العمال في المصانع همم
شعاراتهم تنادي بالعداله الاجتماعيه او
اكثر من ذلك لتصل الى شعارات ربما تطالب
بقلب النظام او تغييره
الان في هذه الاحتجاجات لم تبقى الشعارات
مطلبيه
يبدو بان الجميع اتفق المطالب لا يمكن
الوصول اليها من خلال الا من خلال تغيير
هذا النظام هذا يبدو من خلال الشعراء وليس
موقف مني انا مثلا
عندما نسمع الشعار الموت للديكتاتور
لازم توجد وراء هذا الشعار قضايا مطلبيه
هناك مطلب واحد المطالب برحيل النظام لذا
حتى العمال عندما يحتجون في هذه الايام
بدلا من ربط شعارات مطلبيه يرفعون شعار
الموت
للديكتاتورت اساليب الاحتجاج الاحتجاجات
كانت اسبوع 10 ايام الان نحن حوالي 63 يوم
لدينا احتجاجات يوميا والان طورت خلال
اليومين الاخيرين من الاحتجاجات في
الشوارع الى اضراب المحال التجاريه اليوم
لم تبقى مدينه الا واغلقت المحل التجاريه
للانضمام الى الاحتجاجات
شكرا جزيلا لتواجدك معنا
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
المبعوث الروسي الى افغانستان ينتقدوا
حكومه طالبان ويقول انها لم تتخذ خطوات
عمليه لتشكيل الحكومه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه اكد مدير عام
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رافائيل
جروس اكد ان التحقيق في اثار اليورانيوم
بثلاثه مواقع ايرانيه سريه لن يغلق الا
بعد الحصول على اجوبه جروس يقال انه من
مصلحه ايران التعاون مع الوكاله الدوليه
مشيرا الى ان المساله بعيده عن التسييس
وسيكون لها اثر فاعل في استعاده الثقه
الدوليه في برنامجها النووي دراسي اضاف ان
الوكاله لم تصل الى نقطه توافق مع ايران
في غالبيه القضايا وانه لا يوجد تقدم يذكر
بشان المفاوضات النوويه مع ايران
على كل المزيد معنا من الفينا مو مفردات
العربيه الى هناك راغده بهنام اهلا بك
راغده قراءه في هذه التصريحات وكيف ستنعكس
على اجتماعات الوكاله
اهلا بك يا ميسون يعني هو التحذير شديد
اللهجه صدر عن رفايل جروسي الى ايران هو
قال بان من مصلحتها انت تعاون هو بالطبع
لم يحدد ما هي العواقب في حل لم تتعاون
ايران ولم يقل ما هي المهل الزمنيه قال
انا لو احب المها للزمانيه ولكنه اضافيه
لا يمكن ان تستمر هذه التحقيقات من دون
الحصول على اجوبه لاشهر ولسنوات ونحن الان
يعني ميسون نتحدث عن سنوات لانه هذا
التحقيق الذي يطالب جروستي بالحصول على
اجوبه فيه فتحته الوكاله عام 2018 يعني
قبل بالفعل قبل ثلاث سنوات او اربع سنوات
من الان وما زالت لم تحصل على الاجوبه
التي تريدها والان رغم انه هذه التحقيقات
ايضا او هذا التحقيق بتعقب امام التوقيع
او حتى العقبات امام التوقيع على اعاده
احياء الاتفاق النووي ما زال راسي يرفض
التخلي عنه اغلاقه كما كانت تطالب ايران
كواحد من شروطها للتوقيع على يعني احياء
هذه المحادثات لذلك هو قال انه بقرار من
مجلس محافظين او من دون قرار انا لن اوقف
هذا التحقيق حتى احصل على اجوبه يعني
احصل على اجوبه هل نتوقع قرار بالنهايه او
لا
يعني نحن نتوقع ان يطرح هذا المشروع
القرار الذي ستقدمه الدول الغربيه اما ليل
اليوم لان الاجتماعات تستمر حتى التاسعه
ليلا تقريبا ويني ستناقش ايران او صباح غد
في حال لم يكن هناك وقت كافي الليله همم
لطرح هذا المشروع ما اذا كان سيمر ام لا
على الارجح سيمر لانه تركيبه المجلس وبحسب
التصويت في المره الماضيه يعني في المره
الماضيه من اصل 35 دوله اعترضت دولتين فقط
يا روسيا والصين كان هناك بعض الدول التي
امتنعت عن التصويت ولكن يعني اقل قرار يجب
ان يحصل على اغلبيه او على يعني النصف
+ 1 حتى يمر لذلك على الارجح بانه هذا
القرار سمر همم هذه المره ايضا وهذا
بالطبع سيزيد الضغوط همم على ايران مره
جديده يعني سيكون القرار الثاني الذي
يطالب ايران بالتعاون مع الوكاله خلال
الاقل من سته اشهر هذا امر غير مسبوق يعني
يكون رد فعل الايراني والى اي احد من
المراقبين من يرى انه ما يحدث في الداخل
الايراني ربما قد يضغط عليها للتساهل في
الطاعات مع هذا الملف
يعني خلال المؤتمر الصحفي الذي عقده يعني
اليوم عن ما اذا كان يتخوف من رد فعل
ايران ولكنه قال بانه يعني هو بحاجه
للحصول على الاجوبه ويعني يبدو بانه رد
فعل ايران ليس الان محل قلق لانه اصلا
ايران لا تتعاون المره الماضيه اذا يعني
كنت تذكرين ايران رده با اقفال كاميرات
المراقبه التي كانت ركبتها بحسب الاتفاق
عام 2015 وايضا زادت من اجهزه تطرد المركز
المتطوره يعني ما زاد من قدرتها بطبيعه
الحال على تخصيب الايرانيوم لذلك الان
بالفعل هذا القلق الكبير ولكن مع ذلك
الدول الغربيه لا ترى بان هناك خيار غير
زياده الضغوط الديكلوماسيه عليها لكي
يجعلها لتعود لطاوله او التعاون مع
الوكاله العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك
والان الى موجز الخامسه الرياضي مع الزميل
محمد القناص محمد
كرواتيا لكره القدم على نظيره السعودي
بهدف دون رد خلال مباراه الوديه جمعتهم
الاربعاء استعدادا لبطوله كاس العالم في
قطر وسجل اندريهتش هدفا المباراه الوحيد
في الدقيقه الثانيه والثمانين وينافس
المنتخب السعودي في المجموعه الثالثه مع
منتخبات الارجنتين وبولندا والمكسيك ويبدا
مبارياته في البطوله بمواجهه المنتخب
الارجنتيني يوم الثلاثاء المقبل المقبل
يلعب هو المنتخب الكرواتي في المجموعه
السادسه في بطوله كاس العالم الى جوار
منتخبات المغرب وكندا وبلجيكا حيث يستاهل
وهو مبارياته بمواجهه المنتخب المغربي يوم
الاربعاء
ويواجه منتخب المغرب نظيره منتخب جورجيا
غدا في الشارقه ضمن استعدادات اسود الاطلس
لنهائيات كاس العالم وسيكون لقاء جورجيا
لاختبار الاخير لابناء المدرب وليد
الرجراجي قبل افتتاح المشوار في المونديال
في الثالثه والعشرين من الشهر الجاري امام
كرواتيا ضمن المجموعه السادسه التي تضم
ايضا منتخبات بلجيكا وكندا
ويبدو انس الزروري الانجليزيه المرشحه
الاوفره حظا لتعويض غياب امين حارس لاعب
اولمبيك مارسيليا في قائمه المنتخب
المغربي المشاركه للمره السادسه في
نهائيات كاس العالم في قطر وقامت ضروري
بتغيير جنسيته الرياضيه من البلجيكيه الى
المغربيه في خطواتنا اخيره قبل الانضمام
لمنتخب اسود الاطلس في الدوحه
الحمد لله فاجواء ااا جيده
لاعبين يعني جاء اجمعنا واليومه
بعدين وجدوا المقابله الاولى ليها تكون
اسيمه
مش يحقق ان شاء الله الفوز
اعلن الاتحاد الفرنسي
لاعب زيك في قائمه المنتخب فرنسا المشاركه
في المونديال وتعرض لكم باصابه في الركبه
خلال التدريب المنتخب امس بعد التدخل
القوي اين هو وزميله في الفريق ادواردو
كمانجا مهاجمه موجود حاليا في اليابان مع
نادي سينظم لمنتخب فرنسا في الدوحه صباح
الخير
ربما يصونيون من قائد منتخب كوريا
الجنوبيه الى بعثه منتخب بلاده حيث ظهر في
تدريبات فريقه بعدما تعرض لشرق حول عينه
اليسرى خلال مباراه فريقه المحلي توتنهام
هوتسبير امام مارسيليا في دوري الابطال
وتستاهل لكوريا الجنوبيه مشوارها في
مونديال قطر بمواجهه اوروغواي ثم اتقان في
قبل ان تختفي مع مبارياتها في المجموعه
الثامنه امام البرتغال
اكد البرتغالي مدرب المنتخب
الحريه في التضامن مع الاحتجاجات التي
تشهدها ايران وذلك خلال مشاركتهم في بطوله
كاس العالم لكن
وبحسبرج فان ذلك يخضع الى قواعد اللعبه
اللاعبون تعرضوا الانتقادات الشديده على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في الايام
الماضيه بعد اجتماعاته مع قاده ايرانيين
قبل المغادره الى الدوحه
وصل منتخب الاكوادور الى قطر استعداداته
الاخيره قبل المباراه الافتتاحيه لكاس
العالم امام قطر على احد المقبل وتجمع
العديد من الجماهير الاكوادريه لالقاء
التحيه على منتخب البلاد لدى وصوله الى
الفندق الخاص به في الدوحه لخوض بطوله كاس
العالم الاكوادور تلعب في المجموعه الاولى
الى جانب قطر السنغال وهولندا
وقف النجم البولندي برشلونه روبرت
ليفاندوفسكي ثلاثه مباريات في الدوري
الاسباني لكره القدم بعد ان اظهر عدم
احترام للحكم في احدى المباريات بالبطوله
وستدخل العقوبه حيز التنفيذ عند استئناف
الموسم بعد نهايه مونديال قطر 2022
الموتور ده المهاجم البولنديه بطاقتين
صفرانين ضد ساسونا في الثامن من نوفمبر
حيث قام بالامائه من خلال لمس انفه اثناء
مغادرته ارض الملعب معتبر اساءه للحكم
المحتملف النادي اللي كتالوني قرار
الاتحاد الاسباني
قرار مجلس الوزراء العراقي تخصيص الدعم
الماليه لمساندتي وتامين متطلباتي بطوله
كاس الخليج في نسختها الخامسه والعشرين
التي تستضيفها البصره اعتبارا من السادس
لغايه 19 من يناير المقبل واعلنت الحكومه
العراقيه تضمين هذه التخصيصات الماليه ضمن
الموازنه العامه للبلاد لعام 2023 ذلك
لستدي متطلبات البطوله والتي بلغت ثلاثه
او 30 مليون دولار
لما يسون تستكمل الخميسه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لدى العراق
لينا روما نوسكي في لقاء خاص مع العربيه
قالت ان الهجمات الايرانيه على العراقين
ووحده الاراضي العراقيه تحدن للسياده
العراقيه وان واشنطن تدين هذه الهجمات
الايرانيه على المواطنين العراقيين ووحده
الارض العراقيه هو تحدي لسياده العراقيه
نحن هنا في بغداد واشنطن كذلك ندين هذه
الهجمات مقتل المواطن الامريكي في بغداد
كان حدثا محزنا وماساويا جدا تعازينا
لعائلته واطفاله وزوجته نحن الان نعمل مع
السلطات العراقيه للتحقيق في الحادثه
هلا المباشر رئاسه الروسي الى افغانستان
زميركا بولوف قال انها السلطات الافغانيه
لم تتخذ خطوات عمليه لي تشكيل حكومه
عراقيه وسياسيه شامله
بنفس التكوين غالبا اعتمدنا بيان المشتركا
حافه احدى نقاطه السلطات الافغانيه في
كابول على اتخاذ خطوات عمليه لتشكيل حكومه
عرقيه وسياسيه شامله للاسف لم يحدث ذلك في
ظل هذه الظروف قررنا توجها الدعوه فقط
لدول الاقليميه اخرى الى التنسيق مع موسكو
لتطوير نهج المشترك
السابق الترشح لانتخابات الرئاسه
الامريكيه في 20 24 معتبرا ان عوده امريكا
تبدا الان حسب قوله طبعا هو الامر الذي
يجعله خامس معركه العوده للبيت الابيض
نبقى في الولايات المتحده حيث اقلع اقواس
صاروخ في العالم اس ال اس اليوم للمره
الاولى من فلوريدا في بدايه مهمه ارتميس
للعوده الامريكيه الى القمر في هذه
التجربه والتي تنطلق بعد نصف قرن من اخر
رحله امريكيه الى القمر ضمن برنامج ابولو
لن تهبط الكبسوله غير الماهوله على القمر
بس تقترب منه عندما سافه تصل الى 64,000
كيلو متر في رقم قياسي
لمركبه قابله للسكن
3 2 1
الخامس انتهت شكرا لمتابعه مشاهدينا ابقوا
معنا